the one thing that dirt dog was missing
was a 48 inch version of their tiller
these are top of the line tillers and
they had them available in five six and
seven foot we've been selling them for
years now I've been asking them when are
you gonna come out with a 48 inch well
guess what you're looking at it right
here it is available the same thing as a
bigger version just four foot wide this
is brand new just arrived still on the
frame haven't even taken it out yet but
we're excited to show you put it in
action gonna be a great fit for the
subcompact tractors all right so your 10
25s your Kubota BX similar coyotes my
hendras all that kind of thing as well
hit subscribe if you want to see more of
the future or if you want one for
yourself you can order it up at
goodworkstrackers.com we ship Nationwide
all right